and Ellie's flaming [__] arrows come near
me I'll strangle you with your own guts any
man dies with a clean sword I'll rape his
[__] cop [__] the water bring me wine
can I get you some iced milk and a nice bowl
of raspberries chew it [__] wolf [__] the
Kingsguard [__] the city [__] the King
[__] the King [__] Joffrey [__] the
Queen there's a price on your weight that's
what the King does when you tell me to [__]
off what about the king he can die just fine on
his own Thoris the [__] you doing here what
in seven hells are you doing with the stark
[__] you think you're good with that bow
coward's weapon you look like a bunch of
swineherds are you doing leading a mob of
peasants come try it Archer house shove those
arrows up your eyes all you want closest you've
been to family since Ilyn Payne snipped your
daddy's neck he killed Lommy what the [__]
a Lommy here's my friend ocean name just saw
lots of people name their swords lots of [__]
I understand that have any more words come
pouring out your [__] mouth I'm gonna have
to eat every [__] chicken in this room this
is my land I'm standing on it is my land and
keep it from the clutches of depravity you got
to do all seven of the [__] father he's weak
he can't protect himself how many stars they got
to behead before you figure it out I can't sleep
until I say the names the names of every [__]
person in Westeros if you were here right now
what would you do I'm telling to shut the [__]
up so I can get some sleep the hell you're doing
practicing what ways to die that's no way to fight
it's not fighting it's water dancing dancing maybe
I ought to put on a dress who taught you that
shite the greatest swordsman who ever lived I
bet his hair is greasy than Joffrey's [__]
the greatest swordsman who ever lived killed
by Meryn [__] Trant that number any boy
[__] with a sword could beat three Meryn
greatest thoughts whenever lived in our sword
dad like all the rest of your friends thanks to
you I'm a walking bag of silver anywhere the
Lannisters hold sway family honor all that
horseshit so you lords and ladies ever talk about
there's no safety you dumb [__] those are your
last words [__] you come on you can do it yawns
your [__] dying you know that drop that arrow
you bloody go so far girls and you've tried to
kill me bunch of menses bad night to be outdoors
you've got real powerful magic to figure that out
the Lord of Light whispered that in your ear you
want some rum don't mind that [__] is too sweet
I'll tell you what doesn't scare me bold [__]
like you you think you're fooling in on with that
top not bold [__] it's my [__] luck I end up
with a band of fire worshippers almost seems
like divine justice there's no divine justice
you dump can't if there was you'd be dead dumb
[__] the Lord of Light far fiatter sake well
you shut your hole are we coming with you're not
so what your whingeing about I'm not winded your
lips are moving and you're complaining about
something that's whinging just what I've been
killed six times you don't hear him bitching
about it the dog [__] off I don't give two
shits about Wildings gingers I hate don't point
your [__] finger at me will you [__] off you
want to suck my dick is that it dick talk dick I
like it but you're doing how did I'm mad [__]
like you live this long I'm gonna kill beat we'll
meet again to again talking or not what's in there
[__] off use every bad idea some banister cut
behind it you're even [__] uglier than I am now
I'm just saying it's a tricky material to know
who makes weapons for the wildlings couples and
[__] which one are you your whole little
[__] hunt you Oh for [__] sake there's
well we had a bloody wedding when like Thoris
isn't here anymore so he'll be no about to give
a sermon because if you are the Lord Allah is
gonna wonder why I brought you back 19 times
just to watch you die when I Chuck you over this
[__] wall [__] give up on a [__] off we
got read them oh you see that you do it all my
heart is broken don't touch me yeah that's you
that's what you've always been